in the elite world of close-up magic
Aussie wind has long been considered a
magician's magician his expertise is now
being showcased off Broadway in Aussie
wind's Inner Circle produced by David
Blaine Wynn pulled a few mind-blowing
tricks on our Jamie wax who's so excited
he was talking about the segment during
the commercial break which is why I
looked over at him Jamie good morning
can't wait to see this it's so true I
mean until that was you Jeff I don't
know what what existed but good morning
he did indeed blow my mind and the minds
of everyone in his audience but also
pulled off the far more difficult trick
of touching our souls
you're going to take one card you read
the name out loud if you hear your name
please stand up in your very spot in the
global community of close-up magic
everything is about the details and read
it out loud say the name out loud and no
one pays more attention to detail Jackie
root please stand up then Aussie wind
[Applause]
defies even all other magicians there's
a beautiful Brotherhood in Magic that
doesn't exist in many fields you know
sharing ideas and jamming and oh let me
show you this I'll show you that trading
secrets that really appeals to me that's
it's one of the things that Drew me to
into this world
um you have a brother somewhere in the
world that loves this esoteric art in a
way this esoteric art is something that
makes wondrous and happily connected
children out of even the most cynical
audiences the show's title is also a nod
to the space's design Aussie wins Inner
Circle is exactly that a circle leaving
nowhere to hide from his audience you
are connecting with human beings because
you really want to celebrate the
connection of the experience for the
audience it's true if if you there's all
sorts of magic and styles and schools of
magic so for example you can be the kind
of guy who hey come and see what I can
do and it's aside everybody's just
watching and they do some beautiful
magic things disappear change whatever
and there's the kind of guys like me
that it's really a dialogue performing
on the streets taught me something very
important that dialogue includes
Aussie's personal Journey as well born
in Israel as Assi batesh he eventually
set out for America and started doing
street magic just a short distance away
from the Greenwich Village Theater he
now headlines
this was the most welcoming uh spot for
a street performer even now we're
walking here you see that green person
over there yes I do he belongs here and
there's arts and Painters and his guitar
people only New York right I'm from
Connecticut
he ended up perfecting his art to the
point that I couldn't resist asking him
to give me an improvised sample all
right so let's let's try something okay
it's a little new so do you have a phone
on you I do may I absolutely and open to
a camera okay
and if you don't mind I'll I'll try to
just take a photo of you holding my
wallet okay so there's nothing this
really is your wallet I see your license
don't read it yeah hold it right here
and hold it right there it's empty right
it's uh I decompartment empty yes okay
there's nothing I want you to hold it
this way okay just take a photo of you
holding my wallet
okay so this is the photo I'll keep it
right here okay right there I don't want
to touch anything but can you close this
yep and lock it and then close the whole
thing perfect
so think of any card you want okay if
you want it can change it doesn't matter
to me you have a you have a card in mind
I do name It For the First Time six of
Spades six of it would it be fair to say
that you don't know where is the six of
Spades absolutely yes you're gonna I'm
gonna don't make me Force you or
anything but you'll find it so point to
any card you want anyone that you like
and pull it halfway out okay halfway out
this one oh this one okay if that's the
six of Spades would that be impressive
yes can I ask you but be honest you
don't don't from one to ten
from one to 10 how impressive is it uh I
mean I'd put it at a nine for sure
really yeah so I'm going for 10. so okay
no no we'll do different no no I'm going
for 10. you said six of Spades I did
look I do this
in the six of Spades is shot out of the
deck and went yeah inside the the wall
can you open the wallet yourself I've
been watching this I know my entire time
okay can you please open open that flap
and open the other flap
you know what you know what let's let's
try to Top This and boy did he ever top
it take this card I will look away short
to everybody in yourself okay go ahead
okay
good yeah push it in the middle of the
deck somewhere sure and combine the two
halves and I'll turn yes okay so right
now there's a card in here that you saw
and you like this card to do you want to
change it no it's good it's good okay
good card I'm gonna make it go to the
wallet again
nope nope
no no no not this wallet
remember we took a photo of the wallet
yeah it what was the card two of Hearts
oh two hearts so the two hearts went
inside the wallet in the photo
yeah
open to yeah to Alaska yeah all right in
the very last photo
I am holding the two of Hearts folks
just unbelievable it's seemingly
miraculous moments like this that led
world famous Illusionist David Blaine to
lend his name as presenter of Aussie's
show David and I bonded we became
friends way before we work together
first of all I I thought all these
things that people were doing like
buried alive in this I thought it's all
fake that it's all just tricks and when
I start working with David I realize
it's all real he's doing it for real
Blaine and other icons of magic are
featured in a gallery of artwork outside
the performance space
these are my heroes in Magic my inner
circle and each was painted by Aussie
wind himself die Vernon is also known as
the professor this is Juan tamarit the
master from Spain the great Ricky J who
also figured out a way to make close-up
magic theatrical it was pick it was
particular and very very detriented and
an amazing Storyteller and then I think
we have to talk about Harry Houdini
being Jewish being in Israeli we took a
lot of pride in the fact that he is the
most famous Jewish person in the world
and part of what is special about
Aussie's performing art one day I had
this idea to start with the deck of
cards it's all blank and to allow the
audience to fill in I mean this person
can obviously see without reading
glasses is that people leave not just
amazed or entertained this person
didn't give up
but deeply profoundly moved I want the
audience to teach me something the
journey at least for me
is about growth it's about let's go a
place where I've never been before and I
don't know where it is if I know I would
stop searching
so to me that's that's a beautiful thing
so I hope whatever Journey I'm going to
take next is going to teach me more
I mean this is at the Jimmy Judson in
the West Village if someone is lucky
enough to be in new orle New York uh I'm
sorry I said New Orleans
but uh you should definitely see it it
it is miraculous mind blown that's how
long is he playing for it's it's been
extended it might be extended again who
knows I think so yeah I really do it it
is a really wonderful evening of
connection and that's what you feel I
all right we'll be right back dish was
coming up next
[Music]
is the picture still in your phone it is
it's like I had to check it yes yes my
kids asked me at Christmas to check it
because I described the trick but it is
in my phone with the card with the two
of Hearts
yeah he's so amazing did he tell you did
he show you no no it's not revealed to
me but it is really you know what's
what's profound about it is that and I
think our our executive producer Brian
Applegate will agree it it is about the
connection of of of the sense of wonder
wonder in human beings and it's
wonderful it's a great night out it
really is is it truly magic yes it is I
mean if if there's a definition for
magic yes is it magic or is a trick is
it trick magic or is it magic or is it I
think it's magic I don't know let's try
and let's just say it's magic you can
call it whatever you want it's
fascinating yes it is fascinating
magical I would say that okay yes I
think it's fascinating
I think the same things we did
Copperfield you know things that he just
they just you know they just they figure
out how to do things that blow your mind
away but some folks really can read
minds and I mean I've I don't know how
else to explain it I've been to one of
these magicians and they work with cards
and that's different it's great it's a
little bit different machine so I'm
reading Minds no no but it's a matter
it's part of the magic trick
but uh yeah this was magical
I'd say that